chairperson distinguished guests
faculty
is it a distinguished ladies and
gentlemen
I throw the School of International and
public affairs for the invitation to
speak at this forum and for your kind
words of introduction I understand that
last year columbia university celebrated
its 250th anniversary let me extend
albeit belatedly since they are
congratulations to the entire university
community it is fascinating that a 250
years old at 250 years old columbia is
still growing strong and maintaining is
exemplary standard of academic
excellence there are new few countries
in the world whose leaders in public
life business science and the humanities
have not been had some association with
columbia university indeed there is
hardly any country that has not
benefited from Columbia's outstanding
contribution to knowledge over the years
many sirenians to have been fortunate
enough to be a part of this fine
institution both students and staff
incidentally my son obtained his
master's degree in this university it is
an honor to be here at Columbia
University and just speak at the world
of world leaders from this morning I
thank you for this singular honor this
forum serves as a center for open
dialogue with world leaders what I
believe it also provides a friendly
environment for learning for
in other words it provides an
opportunity for us to share with the
audience some lessons learned in such
areas as war and peace economic and
social development an international
cooperation we in SE Leon have learned
many challenges challenging lessons over
the past 14 years I would like to share
with you a few namely conflict
management and post-conflict development
it is our experience in resolving
conflicts and literally building a
bridge between post-conflict recovery
and sustainable development while taking
you through conflict we reflect and
finally to development in this weapon
free comfort zone of Columbia University
I look forward to learning through
exchange of views on these matters you
may be aware there's a lien has endured
a decade-long in internal conflict in
the 1990s that unleashed a campaign of
unimaginable bloodshed and devastation I
will not recount here in full detail the
extra-ordinary brutality and immense
suffering visited upon the people of my
country during the course of the
conflict which left hundreds of
thousands dead and many more grotesquely
named the conflict also devastated our
infrastructure as a result this
senseless violence and wanton
destruction the conflict in Salem became
internationally known for its horrific
atrocities particularly the widespread
amputation of
civilians and sexual violence
perpetrated against innocent women and
children prior to the outbreak of the
armed conflict civilian was not only a
developing country but also one of the
least developed in the world it's delays
here 70 years 77 the 11-year rebel
conflict only exacerbated and already
fragile economy however the killing and
maiming were abated and the guns and
governors island by our commitment to
end the conflict and the wheel of the
people for a return to democratic
governance today one of our greatest
achievements is our adherence to the
tenants of democracy and the rule of law
upon assuming the presidency in March
1996 my own personal experience in
post-conflict recovery as a UNDP
representative and resident coordinator
of the United Nations system in eastern
southern Africa was put to the test in
my own country I inherited a severely
battered nation I was conscious of my
political constitutional and also moral
obligation to strive hard and exert
every effort to bring an early end to
the wall the population had already
become war weary and in spirit of my
knowledge of the state of our military
and it's in ability to prosecute the war
against the rebels I made the enduring
the ending of the wall my campaign
pledge I made this pledge and the belief
that by negotiations and sound reasoning
I would be able to talk the rebels out
of their hostile activities against the
population and press you ate them to
enter into negotiations with a view to
concluding a peace agreements with them
in fact the only option i saw available
to me then was to embark on negotiations
with the rebels accordingly that that is
the approach that i pursued immediately
after my inauguration despite the
existing problems concerning the
capability of the military and the fact
that I was elected president against the
background of increasing confidence of
the eighth of the eventual access
ascendancy to power of the rebel group
known as the revolutionary united front
are you f a cross-section of my people
including the print media was against
negotiations with the rebels but I knew
that did then army not the people had
lost the war and since the people were
not combatants in the strict sense of
the word I convinced them into talking
with the rebels it was an uphill task
the Arias manifests hostility towards my
government had been further increased by
insistence on elections before peace
this caused the area of a considerable
sense of frustration both of these
factors though not fatal would pair will
prove to wicking the bargaining position
of my government when it entered the
Ibiza
peace talks with the area of revels in
late nineteen ninety-six in abidjan a
comprehensive peace agreement was
concluded in spite of the acrimony
engendered by the rebels during the
negotiations the agreement called for
among other things the total and
immediate cessation of hostilities the
disarmament demobilization and
reintegration of all combatants and the
provision of an amnesty for the RDF
members the people of Ceylon welcomed
the signing of this agreement as the
AeroGarden record as the end of their
Wars and suffering and expected that it
would restore lasting peace and
stability to the country it's soon
turned out however that people and the
government had in fact been deceived by
the area a message from the rebel leader
intercepted by the government only days
after the signing of the agreement
clearly showed that the area did not
enter the peace negotiations in good
faith and had no desire to abide by the
terms of the resulting peace agreement
in that message for this ankle the rebel
leader had communicated with his deputy
the field commander sambo curry aliased
mesquita that he had agreed to
participate in a negotiation and to sign
the peace agreement only as a protects
to relieve himself of the pressure of
the international community that he
never intended to abide by it by its
terms in the same message he ordered his
commanders to resume hostilities even
with greater ferocity indeed the
ceasefire which then prevailed
was unilaterally broken by the area
immediately after the signing of the
agreement a clear indication that the
abidjan agreement was doomed to fail
attacks on civilians by the area stepped
up over time in March 1997 military
officers adopted the name Armed Forces
Revolutionary Council in collaboration
with the area rebels and staged a bloody
coup in freighter the capital of Syria
my government went into exile in
neighboring Guinea from where we
operated and mobilize international
support for the immediate and
unconditional restoration of democratic
rule the people of Sierra Leone
overwhelmingly we just rejected the coup
some with their lives in response to the
area of intransigence and it's
increasing brutality against civilians
Nigerian led economic community
monitoring observer group ECOMOG troops
launched an offensive in February 1998
to dislodge the janta the joint Air
Farce the area of Fighters were forced
out of Freetown and my government was
thereafter restored during the
intervention by ecomo however many of
the afrc and aerial forces escaped to
the remote hinterlands of the country
and intensified their activities
predominantly in the diamond mining
areas there they were able to mine
diamonds which they exchanged cheaply
for weapons with which they armed
themselves study teeth this enabled them
to regroup
the regroup and attack the capital in
January 1999 slaughtering thousands of
civilians and virtually raising the city
in a matter of days this level of mayhem
and destruction for the awakens genuine
international away awareness to the
plight of the civilian population that
incursion accelerated the dare need for
the peace process in color in
collaboration with the economy Community
of West African states a coerce the
international community was now willing
to intervene at least diplomatically and
there together with the government we're
now determined to find a workable and
lasting solution to the rebel menace in
the country this led to the commencement
of the dialogue which resulted in the
norm a peace agreement of 1999 the
initial stage of the dialogue was set
when I was invited to low me in Togo to
sign his ceasefire agreement with a
rebel leader for his ankle in March 1999
like this I did this amidst a lot of
misgivings from the people of Surrey
Leon from the bitter experience they had
had regarding for the San Jose attitude
to the a bichon peace accord they on the
one hand preferred an all-out war
against the rebels and are not
attainment of peace by their defeat in
battle I on the other hand was aware of
the handicaps and limitations of the
government to perceive that way I was
also aware of a pending restoration of
the democratically elected government in
Nigeria as a result of which the
continued stay
of the Nigerian contingent in a coma in
Sierra Leone which was by far the
largest could not be guaranteed above
all else I could no longer stomach the
killing of innocent civilians thus I
chose the path of dialogue again but
this time careful to avoid the pitfalls
and weaknesses in the abidjan peace ago
accord along the lines of the abidjan
peace agreement the Lumia peace accord
included a blanket amnesty for
competence and provided for disarmament
and demobilization and the reintegration
of human rights and truth and
reconciliation commissions the party is
also agreed to the deployment of a
neutral United Nations peacekeeping
force most notably it also included a
power-sharing arrangement among the
elected government the are you f and
rebels and the afrc the area of leader
for this ankle was accorded a status
that was similar to that of the vice
president and chairmanship of the
important Commission for the management
of strategic mineral resources and
natural national reconstruction and
development the APC the afrc leader
johnny pole koroma was appointed
chairman of the disarmament and
reintegration committee with these
arrangements expectations were high thus
a Lyon had turned the corner and was on
his way to lasting peace and stability
January 18 2002 Sarah unions place a
high SI of joyous relief
for that memorable day marks the formal
end of the brutal conflict we set
ourselves specific goals in pursuit of
sustainable peace and national
development we share the view that a
peaceful and stable environment is sani
quinone for national development and by
extension for achieving the Millennium
Development Goals the sherry the
starting point was the sama means and
reintegration of competence by mid-2004
a total of seventy 2490 combatants were
disarmed and seventy 1043 Damali
demobilized including 6845 child
soldiers by the same period 55,000 122
ex-combatants have received support for
their integration into active community
life also most of the formerly
internally displaced persons and of
refugees were repatriated and resettled
indeed the war did killed our people and
ravaged our country had become a thing
of the past however in order to ensure
that the long piece is consolidated
government impact on no sustainable
reforms in the security sector the
underlying strategy is to transform the
security sector so that it is not only
capable of responding adequately to
threats to the state and citizen
citizenry but also to provide the
enabling enabling environment to fight
poverty and pursue the goals of national
development this is particularly
significant
as what was once a seventeen thousand
personnel strong UN peacekeeping force
unum still is scheduled to depart from
say Leone in within three months that is
by the end of this year as I pursued the
peace process I was also cognizant of
the fact that say Leoneans were anxious
not only to have peace but also to
realize sooner rather than later
concrete dividends from this rest from
the restoration of a democracy of a
democratic government which they had
obtained after much toil and suffering
we were constantly reminding ourselves
that lack of development breeds conflict
and insecurity how then do you will keep
the peace and maintain security under
those circumstances while regarding
peace and security as being paramount we
never abandoned our relief and
development responsibilities to this end
one of the most successful of our
post-conflict initiatives was the
establishment of a national commission
for reconstruction resettlement and
rehabilitation the three hours hours as
we called it while it was evidently a
response to the humanitarian development
goals in particular for the rural areas
which bore the brunt of rebel aggression
the NC Triple R was in effect a bridge
between the demand for immediate
humanitarian relief and the equally
important need to prepare for a
resumption of economic
meant activities that had been
ruthlessly disrupted by the rebel war
after all people can not remain or
depend on humanitarian relief
indefinitely moving from relief to
development the triple our commission
was transformed into the national
commission for social action Maxo NASA
could be described as the motive force
for our post-conflict development it is
a showpiece in post-conflict transition
while assuming responsibility for the
previous reconstruction resettlement and
rehabilitation program Maxo also
coordinates funding for projects that
promote economic growth and sustainable
development working directly with local
communities it supports projects and
programs in such areas as water and
sanitation shelter public works
including feeder roads agriculture
fisheries education and micro financing
with almost 1,100 projects implemented
the ultimate objective of Nazca is
linked to our poverty reduction strategy
as stated above even before the war
poverty in Sierra Leone had become
endemic and pervasive by 1990 statistics
indicates that those includes 24 fifth
of the population lived below the
poverty line of one dollar a day in
addition to income poverty a large
portion of the population lacked access
to basic social services including
healthcare education potable water and
sanitation
the world merely exhibited the depth and
severity of poverty causing the living
conditions of the majority to further
deteriorate following the election in
1996 my government began efforts to
combat widespread poverty we began by
identifying five broad development
priorities one security and war related
issues such as the sama mean
demobilization reintegration and reset
resettlement rehabilitation and
reconstruction to education three good
governance and justice for agriculture
and food security and five health with
an emphasis on primary health care and
in order to address these broad
developmental priorities we devised a
property reduction strategy in the form
of an interim poverty reduction strategy
paper which was completed in 2001 this
strategy was designed to support the
transition from peacekeeping to peace
building and from relief to equitable
and sustainable development it called
for a two-phase implementation strategy
a transition period 2001 to 2002 and the
medium-term phase 2003 to 2005 while the
transition period focus on immediate
post-war reconstruction resettlement and
security challenges the medium-term
phase address long-term development
strategy for poverty reduction within
the context of the preparation of a full
poverty reduction paper PRS be in
addition my government also provided for
the implementation
shin of the national recovery strategy
an arrest which was prepared and
launched in october 2002 it focused on a
the consolidation of state authority and
peacebuilding be promotion of
reconciliation and the enforcement of
human rights see facilitating
resettlement and reintegration and
rebuilding communities communities d
facilitating access to previously
inaccessible areas and e stimulating
economic recovery the nirs freeze
represented the combined efforts of
government and development partners and
essentially served as a bridge between
emergency humanitarian assistance and
longer-term development challenges both
the IPR SB and the NRS we are
successfully implemented during 2001 to
2004 with my government allocating
significant budgetary resources to fund
critical poverty reduction activities
particularly in the social sectors of
health education water and sanitation
this resulted in sustained recovery of
the economy during the period 2001 to
two thousand four real gdp grew by four
five point four percent in 2001 6.3 in
2002 6.5 in 2003 and 6.4 in 2004 to
consolidate these games government
support a adopted bold economic and
structural stock structured structural
reforms geared towards sustaining the
recovery and improving overall financial
management and service delivery other
reform measures have included a
improving the strengthening policymaking
budget planning and execution be
improving the capacity for accounting
and reporting see reforming the public
procurement process d enhancing revenue
collection and mechanisms through the
creation of a National Revenue Authority
and see an e public sector reform
generally in order to achieve greater
efficiency in the management of public
finances and to ensure that public
enterprises better serve the public of
Sierra Leone we established a public
enterprise privatization Commission to
oversee and monitor the operations of
state enterprises and recommend their
privatization who are appropriate beyond
that or have been preoccupied with
institutional development as a means of
not only expanding the institutional
space but also of modernizing our
institutions for us so that they can
provide efficient service currently
saloon is aggressively pursuing a new
strategic direction to build towards the
mdg targets it has formulated a 2005 to
2007 prsp which provides bold sectoral
policies and institutional reforms to
achieve economic growth provider food
security job opportunities basic social
services and efficient social security
nets it proposes actions to address a
short-term living conditions
and be long-term causes of conflict and
poverty the poverty reduction strategy
paper constitutes salience first step
towards achieving the Millennium
Development Goals by 2015 it is oriented
towards long-term poverty reduction it
is multi-dimensional and achievable as
we all know however neither the ongoing
efforts of my governments to achieve a
meaningful improvement in the welfare of
our people nor our implementation of
prudent fiscal and monetary problems can
ever be achieved if these efforts are
not firmly rooted in a solid framework
of democratic practices and good
governance that is why we are vigorously
pursuing the goals of good governance
through several reform measures aimed at
improving the performance and integrity
of state institutions fiscal public
sector management and the quality of
public and political leadership on my
assumption of office my government
immediately set up improving the quality
of governance and later set up a
governance steering committee under the
chairmanship of a member of my cabinet
the committee has concentrated its
efforts on rebuilding democratic
governance through constitutional and
institutional reforms decentralization
and local government reforms public
sector and civil service reforms
promotion of Human Rights judicial and
legal reforms promotion and of
accountability and transparency
reduction in the of the incidence of
corruption and abuse of power
in particular my government views
corruption as an impediment to the
promotion of good governance accordingly
combating em endemic corruption is the
cornerstone of our good governance
program we have for the first time in
the history of the alien appointed an
ombudsman whose role is to investigate
complaints of abuse and capricious
action on the part of public officials
also for the first time in our history
and we ahead of other sub-saharan
African countries we have promulgated
and under an anti-corruption act to
combat corruption and establish an
anti-corruption commission with the
mandate to investigate instances of
alleged or suspected corruption and to
take appropriate action including
recommendations for prosecution in a bid
to stimulate economic development the
rural areas and in the rural areas and
to extend democratic participation to
the grass roots of the population the
government introduced legislation in
ally 2004 aimed at promoting
decentralization of government services
and the re-establishment of elected
local government councils this
initiative led to the enactment of the
local government act in March 2004
thereafter local government elections
were held nationwide in May of that year
in which municipal town and district
councils were elected to replace the
heater tour politically appointed
management committees that had been in
place these elections to government
closer to the local community and
considerably empower
them to take control of the management
of their own affairs another serial
source of concern for my government is
that of dealing with the dispensation of
justice in surulere accordingly under
the guidance of the chief justice the
entire judicial and legal system is in
the process of being completely
overhauled this activity which is aimed
at developing an effective and efficient
legal and judicial system in Sierra
Leone is part of the British funded log
development reform project in line with
our commitment we now have a fully
functioning Law Reform Commission whose
mandate is to review all the laws of our
country and to make recommendations
regarding the need for the updating
amendment or repeal of laws further
measures have been taken to provide
incentive and improve pay and other
conditions of service for personnel in
the legal service the cumulative effect
of all these public sector reform
initiatives is the Sailor Lyon is
gradually becoming the peaceful and
wholesome society that it had been known
to be at one time in the past we are
trying to position stay alone among the
ranks of leading countries in Africa we
are leaders in addressing corruption we
will be leaders in human rights will be
leaders in electoral reform we will be
leaders in food security we must
establish this reputation for leadership
in order to begin to attract long-term
foreign investors we need for an
investment first in the development of
infrastructure without adequate energy
telecommunications transport and
shipping services
we will not attract business investment
we're doing our best to provide a
regulatory framework with particular
with the predictable consistent and
simple procedures for doing business
foreign enclaves mark our economic
history especially in the mining and
commercial sectors the business of these
sectors must be true must be thoroughly
integrated into our national economy
this is usually accomplished through the
financial sector including the banks we
must enable national and foreign
investors to lend and borrow money in
the local market the financial links
need to be developed between those who
have money and those who went to invest
money in your businesses our banking
system is starting to vigorous
vigorously respond in his services to
every district now it must expand the
kind of services it provides and MA and
become a true hub for financial
transactions between leaders lenders and
borrowers the microfinance sector is
imagined is emerging financial services
needs to expand to include medium-size
loans on the commercial banks and most
finance agriculture and post-harvest
businesses to link agriculture to
industry private sector growth does not
just refer to foreign investment we're
witnessing a most encouraging response
by farmers on the various initiatives of
from field schools
and agricultural business units last
year the Ministry of Agriculture
Forestry and food security provided she
tries to enable farmers to restore loss
losses during the war and rebuild the
acreage necessary for food security this
year the ministry is purchasing an
additional one hundred and fourteen
thousand bushels of rice making these
two years the largest efforts ever for
government support to expand to the
expansion of rice production the
agricultural business units have pledged
to save twenty percent of their output
and make a community contribution of
twenty percent to their local council
the successful arvest in 2005 to 2006
and the commitment of these traumas to
their pledges will launch a new era of
agricultural business by small farmers
this is an encouraging development in
the private sector we are hopeful that
in 2006 this effort will culminate in
ceylon becoming once again a rice
exporter the task of achieving our own
national development goals and the MDGs
is daunting especially for one of the
least developed countries of the world a
country imagine from 11 years of armed
conflict while acknowledging the need to
strengthen our capacity for good
governance mobilizing domestic financial
institutions etc we have to make
considerable efforts to create modules
to integrate our youth into the economic
and social mainstream of society here
I'm referring to the vast majority who
never lifted an ak-47
rifle against anyone we have learned
from experience than unemployment and
disadvantaged youths provided a pool of
recruits for the rebels we have
therefore created a new Ministry of
Youth and Sports to enhance our ability
through well-designed projects from
meeting the needs of this important
segment of the population in this regard
we have revised our national youth
policy it emphasizes youth empowerment
and the mainstreaming of youth
activities and concerns as critical
inputs in the development process the
major objective is the strengthening of
partnership between the public and
private sectors to facilitate employment
of youth of youth in in coming up with
this new policy we realize that had one
piece as well as our efforts for
sustainable development would be
seriously jeopardized if we fail to
address the earth problem speedily and
effectively we have to eliminate the
risk of us sliding back into conflict
the key lies in prevention we agree with
the secretary-general of the United
Nations that every step taking towards
reducing poverty and achieving
broad-based economic growth is a step
towards conflict prevention we must
create a culture of prevention one based
on renewed commitment to address in a
coordinated and comprehensive manner the
problems of economic and social
development I have no doubt whatsoever
that this is the best means of ensuring
the Saline does not slide back into
violent conflict ladies and gentlemen
let me summarize what I believe based on
this alien experience and lessons
learned are the key elements for meeting
the challenges of post-conflict
development least developed countries
emerging from armed conflict phase
special problems that require special
attention as well as specialized country
specific solutions to sustained economic
and social development is a key to the
prevention of armed conflict and perhaps
the best means of preventing the
recurrence of violence aimed violence
armed cops or a violent armed conflict
in developing countries like Syria three
useless war related emergency relief and
peacekeeping programs buttressed by
comprehensive development programs the
prospects for lasting peace will be them
the vet for development as an instrument
of conflict prevention and durable peace
must also be considered in the context
of regional peace and security for
instance a strong and viable mana river
union comprising Guinea Liberia and
Sierra Leone would help significantly
and could alleviate most of the problems
associated with the conflicts in the
sub-region an equally strong and viable
economy Community of West African states
focusing on its cooperation and
integration would greatly enhance the
capacity of its member states to prevent
and
I've a concept of reintegrating after
armed conflict should be redefined I'm
sorry I think this is a second page yes
should be redefined it should be
extended beyond the placement of X
competence in occupational and related
activities to include the integration of
youth in the mainstream of society and
finally small developing countries how
very limited means to defend themselves
against serious threats to their
security unless major powers and
collective security arrangements are
willing to provide the necessary
assistance when these estates face
serious internal disturbances and all
external aggression they will be doomed
to perpetual turmoil in the next two
years now that we have secured the peace
we will consolidate the peace for future
generations by developing story on we
will be more strategic will be over be
more thorough will will be more
intolerant of corruption we will protect
the rights of women and children we will
secure and improve the education of our
boy girl and of our boy and girl
children we will continue to offer our
youth the chance of our literacy to
recover the basic education they missed
during the wall we will accelerate the
transformation of subsistence farming
into surplus falling or build ability of
our families to save and invest in their
agricultural businesses above all
adhere to the tenants of participatory
democratic governance and the rule of
law we have come a long way thanks to
the invaluable contribution of every
cell unit in diverse ways and to the
support of the international community
of course we acknowledge the fact that
there is still a long way ahead of us
with commitments and hard work on the
part of every cell unit under the
support of friendly countries and
institutions who will achieve the
millennium development goals and targets
finally I hope you can appreciate that
the path to peace and development can be
rugged however with determination
patience people's will proper focus and
the grace of the almighty one is bound
to succeed I thank you for your
attention
you